our next guest is a two-time grammy
award-winning singer and songwriter and
now she's taking pen to paper with her
very first children's book the curly
girl blues everyone please
welcome tori kelly
um
speaking of grammys you're nominated for
two grammys
yes it's a huge huge honor i mean i
remember
being
nominated for the first time for best
new artists like when i was like me
artists and just starting out and it was
this whole like whirlwind of emotions
and that even that just trips me out it
was my childhood dream so the fact that
i like have those is just surreal to me
but
where did your grammys end up
so
so what people don't know
is you like you you go on stage and you
like accept the award and everything and
people think like that's your actual
grammy like you go home with that and
that's not true at all it's like just a
prop so like everyone's just holding the
same grammy and they like and they're
relevant right out of your hand yeah so
you walk off stage and you're like oh my
gosh and they're like thank you so much
and they just take it away
right what are you gonna do i thought
yeah
they send you the
grammys and the mail
like way later so this was like
months and months and months later and i
finally get like a notification
so they were like hey you weren't home
like we tried to deliver this package
and
uh
you know you weren't here so we sent
them to uh like the local drug store you
know you can like pick up just packages
and i we filmed the whole thing because
we thought it was so funny i'd be like
hey i think there's like two packages
here
like this big
they're gold yeah like golden
okay so you are nina insane
nina is such a meaningful
and important character in both movies
and
one of mina's story lines in sing too is
that she is with eric andre darius who's
like totally full of himself and
hilarious but she's not attracted to him
and they have to pretend like they're in
love
so
what happens pharrell is
another one of our amazing co-stars and
he
um he plays an elephant named alfonso
and that is who mina actually has a
crush on and it's so cute and so you
know by the end you're seeing
mina kind of picturing that it's him
instead of darius
uh and that kind of helps her get
through the performance because they
have a duet together and she's like how
am i supposed to pretend that i like
this guy so it's really sweet i love her
storyline in in this movie
i i really also love the fact that you
did not with the grammys and the
starring roles in the big franchise
movies
that is not exactly where your story
started and for me i always like to
laugh and i love the lighter side of
life but i like the depth too what was
the struggle what was the journey like
it wasn't always easy for you
it wasn't no i um
basically you know i mean i went into
record labels and i was like 12 years
old i did
a ton of different like competition tv
shows and you know got a lot of
rejection along the way nothing was
panning out and finally i was like
you know what i've gotten all these no's
i'm gonna just
kind of
take my career into my own hands and
that's when i started just posting
videos online on youtube and just like
doing covers with friends and like
picking up the guitar and just i was
just having so much fun with it i didn't
care anymore like who
was watching and slowly but surely
it you know people started noticing and
i started getting to do shows
and
it's been amazing i mean i think
i think without all of that rejection at
such a young age i mean you know maybe i
wouldn't have had that same like drive
and that same fire
to be able to you know do what i'm doing
now even and your curly girl blues
inspired
um from your own childhood yeah
tell me about that yeah so i
have curly hair and i did not like it
growing up you know at school and stuff
i didn't really see like my hair and i
was very insecure about it and
i wanted to write a book that could
hopefully inspire other kids you know if
i went through this and i didn't like my
hair and was struggling with it you know
there's got to be other kids who also
you know could spoil the same way once
again you took your discomfort and
turned it into your empowerment and
those messages resonate with people they
resonate with me
um so much um as a last question may i
ask you is it true that you were pen
pals with your husband
we were yeah it was very it just wasn't
like flirty at all in the beginning we
were just like writing to each other on
like different sides of the world and
then for like five months we were doing
that and we finally met and it was like
wow we like each other
long story short well i think that goes
to show us all keep writing everybody
it's such an amazing way to communicate
as is writing a children's book head to
the curlygirlblues.com
[Applause]
to get your amazing copy of this amazing
book
[Music]